you want to talk about corrupt
institutions that have ties to
children that do bet i can't even say it
the royal family my goodness gracious
there's
andrew deep down the rabbit holes that
you could go down not just them i heard
rabbit hole they're bad yeah
speaking of rabbit hole yeah so uh what
an excellent segue luke that was perfect
timing
my friends we have to talk about this uh
i'm ashamed of each and every one of you
oh luke ian sydney lydia yeah
critical thinking what were you thinking
the new york times says critically
critical thinking and uh hold on i'm
going to read this for you there's a
quote from the new york times
critical thinking as we're taught to do
it isn't helping in the fight against
misinformation
wait wait check out this first line all
right
for an academic michael caulfield has an
odd request
stop overthinking what you see online
sit down shut up believe what you're
told and move on good sir
yes sir the new york times this is what
they say mr coffield the digital
literacy expert washington state
knows all too well in vancouver mind you
knows all too well at this very moment
more people are fighting for the
opportunity to lie to you than perhaps
any other point in human history
misinformation blah blah blah yeah we
get it
we're taught that in order to protect
ourselves from bad information we need
to deeply engage with the stuff that
washes up in front of us
mr crawfield told me recently he
suggested that the dominant mode of
media literacy
if kids get taught any at all and that's
a good point is that quote
you'll get imperfect information and
then use reasoning to fix that somehow
but in reality
that strategy can completely backfire in
other words resist the lure of rabbit
holes in part
by reimagining media literacy for the
internet hellscape we occupy
let me tell you what's really being said
here because i can translate for all of
you
they don't want you investigating the
news they don't want you listening to
conversations like this
you want to know how easy it is i'll
give you i'll tell you guys all this
how do you know who's actually lying
who's telling the truth the person who's
telling you the truth tells you
to listen to the ideas of other people
and come to your own conclusion to be a
free
sovereign individual why i don't want
power over you
i don't want to own your life or rule
your life or make you do anything for me
i want you
to find what's best for you that
empowers other people
the people who would tell you don't
think critically don't
don't investigate these things don't
watch these other channels
they do want things from you they want
to manipulate they want to control you
they want you for a purpose
i don't care what you do i don't care if
you want to go home just like a banana
and juggle bananas i don't care if
you'll dress up like a clown
and go to a clown party that's your
thing you do your thing
anybody telling you not to do what you
want to do to be free songs not hurting
others
and who would lie to you and tell you
not to listen to others or would censor
opinions
or my stars in garters new york times
saying
don't think critically well they say
people are manipulating but the way they
phrase that
critical thing as we're taught so maybe
what they're implying is we're not being
taught
proper critical thinking skills and i
can kind of identify what maybe he's
saying is that
there's a propensity when you're reading
something to just disbelieve it like you
don't want to believe everything you see
obviously
but you don't want to necessarily
disbelieve it either so
to rebuff ideas and to become so you
know contrastual
just as a reflex is also a problem and
maybe that's what a lot of people are
doing
it's a it's a fair point to say don't go
down the rabbit hole
because then people become flat earthers
and other weird stuff but then saying
critical thinking as we're taught no no
look
i mean i get the point for sure i'll
give them the benefit of the doubt what
they're really saying is
actually think critically they're not
saying that the opening line was don't
overthink things
so what i opened the newspaper and it
says acts just happened
the an american destroyer was attacked
in the gulf of tonkin
don't overthink it it just happened
except it is reality
and then you know the vietnam war starts
and we find out later didn't really
happen
and you know and maybe we should have
overthought that i feel like when you're
at university there's like a big thing
where you are taught
not well to think critically i don't
know if that was you know
anyone else's experience but that was
definitely mine and i feel like maybe
that
i don't think that's what the new york
times is saying just by the way like i
definitely think this is them being like
don't look too deeply into things
because
then you might start questioning
narratives that you're not supposed to
question
but certainly sorry how are you taught
critically like what was yours i just
don't feel like we were i feel like it
was one of those things where like
when i was at school and i so my first
degree was i i studied criminology and
then my second my master was in
journalism because you know here i am
sort of doing that
um but i feel like there wasn't a huge
emphasis on actually digging deeper into
things it was sort of like accept this
on the surface and maybe look a little
bit into it here are the sources the
approved sources that we're okay with
you looking at
don't go beyond these or if you do look
at these these and these and these
because these are you know supplementary
readings
but it wasn't like go and do your own
research and then write me something new
and impressive
that wasn't the emphasis and i feel like
that's what critical thinking is taking
a prompt or an idea or whatever reading
something about it going okay
and then looking deeper and then going
down this hall and going over here and
and basically building
an idea of something from multiple
angles and sources
and coming to your own conclusions we're
not taught to do that i wasn't taught to
do that at school
at university and i feel like a lot of
young people coming out of that system
probably don't have the skills that they
should when it comes to thinking more in
depth about things i'm not saying that
everyone has to be conservative
or has to solely go to conservative
sources and that's all they can read
and that's the only place that's going
to give them true and accurate
information no
look at everything across the board and
then derive your conclusions yeah times
have changed in the last 20 years
especially with the internet because
now looking at everything is impossible
there's so much information relative to
1996
when i was you know in school you can
more easily find the sources
so if someone makes a claim and you
can't verify the source you can question
it
and hold it in doubt we used to trust it
more when the new york times would come
out and say anonymous source told us
this people would be like i guess it's
true because what else we gonna do about
it now we can actually be like hold on
let me look into that
but here's the dangerous thing about
what what the new york times is doing
they hold themselves to a special
standard that's basically it in in the
article they say you know here's some
four principles of what you should do
when you encounter you know potential
disinformation or whatever they say
one stop two investigate the source
three find better coverage
four trace claims quotes and media to
the original context
otherwise known as sift sounds here's a
quote is robert f kennedy jr
the best unbiased source on information
about a vaccine
i'd argue no and that's good enough to
know we should probably just move on he
said
and i'd like to edit in a little
sentence while completely ignoring bill
gates is not a scientist nor
a doctor you see the point when bill
gates comes out
they say everything oh it's great bill
gates has a plan and here's what he's
saying here's his advice
in the new york times says well robert f
kennedy jr was an anti-vaxxer so don't
trust him
it's they apply this standard of we must
not overthink things and must analyze
only when it's the narrative they want
so a good example is how like wikipedia
works for example i can come out and say
something like
i am in favor of a universal health care
system
that also has private health insurance
much like
most of the developed world i am not in
favor of abolishing private
insurance and i was a big fan of bernie
sanders in 2016
and they'll say tim poole is not a good
source
on what he actually believes even when
he says it but then i can come out and
say something like
i am pro 2a and they'll write tim poole
says he is full pro 2a
if it is a right-wing position they'll
say well he said it so it's true
if it's a left-wing position they'll say
nope nope he's not a good source of this
information so tim pool can't be
left-wing
they use whatever narrative they want
they use the rules
only when it best suits them don't think
critically they say
unless of course it's negative you know
something negative against our opponents
in which case you must think critically
and sift and go through the sources
that's the name of the game i suppose
that's media sucks though this is why
the media is i just
i'm gonna start but i mean this is where
the mainstream is
this is just why the mainstream media
really gets under my skin because you're
right like
and i think a lot of conservatives
obviously like being that that's the
space that i occupy a lot of the time is
that conservative libertarian-esque
ground but
a lot of people on the right too i don't
think are willing to admit that the
right wing
is just as bad when it comes to spinning
things or
cherry-picking information and creating
particular narratives around things
where they're not quite telling the
truth for example i mean like even that
coke thing and i'm not defending what
coke did at all i think it
that's gross but i mean they put out a
statement that basically said hey
you know um this is not actually the
sole focus of our curriculum it was just
part i know and you're making a face
with me but i'm just saying like there's
there's that caveat to the story that i
think they're buttholes for what they
did and i think it's disgusting and i
you know like i said i put that in the
video i made i you know i'm trying not
to swear tim it's so hard for me to try
to fight
but it's you know i so so my my point
here is that
you're allowed to be like coke or a
bunch of buttholes and i think that they
suck
you know what they did was shitty and
sorry i was trying i was trying to avoid
it i was trying
you can't
what they did was yucky and we don't
like it and you know whatever
but then you caveat you go but this is
also what they said because then it's a
more
you've you know you you're not dishonest
there's no twist
i don't who's being who's being
dishonest i'm not saying anyone was
being dishonest but i'm saying that in
this context
i'll tell you i'll tell you more
information is better in my opinion
i took issue with the wind wind turbine
story in texas
because all the conservatives like not
all of them but all of these
conservatives are coming out and saying
the wind turbines froze and it shut down
the grid and it caused all the damage
and in reality also gas lines were
freezing and there was a bunch of other
issues
but it does seem because we did have on
one fellow was an
energy expert who basically said if it
wasn't
for the wind turbines going down the
demand for gas wouldn't have skyrocketed
causing this you know domino effect
essentially
but to come out and say that it was the
sole reason for the crisis was
not completely true right so you have
aoc coming out and saying no it's the
problem of the gas lines we need a green
new deal
many on the right saying it's the wind
turbines and i'm like the reality is
they didn't winterize the wind turbines
right there there are wind turbines in
antarctica
and they work because it doesn't snow so
in texas they needed to better winterize
them and prepare for this and it seems
like they weren't prepared for a winter
storm
even though it happened in 2011 right so
it's not entirely
yes there it's fair to say that when the
wind turbines froze up it caused a
cascade effect
texas could have prepared now i hear
them saying that joe biden denied
some emergency relief so it's always
much more complicated than anything
but i will tell you this for the most
part conservatives know what the left is
thinking
and when they write about it they don't
need to snub details
they might give you their biased version
of it sure but the left outright just
manipulates
oh i'm not saying that conservatives
like lie in the same way that the left
does
definitely not but they definitely they
still spin things i still
see things and i go i know for a fact
that what is written in this article
is part of the story and there's a whole
other element to this that if they just
added a single sentence acknowledging
that other part of it
it would be a more holistic better
well-rounded story that people could
read and go
okay i now at least know basically
more or less the full details of it i'm
not saying that i mean the left just
make crap up
that's the thing that head-butting
microphones here that's the thing that
annoys me so much is they just make
things up but i don't know i hate the
media in general like across the board
just because of this
the dishonesty and the twisting of
information i got a a correction
and i'm actually really happy about this
so pointer
i did i did a segment on this on my tim
cass news channel so i i tweeted
something very snarky i said time
magazine
just came out and said that
a cabal rigged the election i'm sorry
they said they didn't rig the election
they fortified it
by changing the rules and the laws and
manipulating the flow of information
it was just snarky but i made no
declaration in this
time magazine said this and then i said
they
i'm sorry they didn't say it was rigged
because i was trying to be silly so
pointer writes an article
and they said a controver you know
controversial youtuber tim poole
published a post which claimed or which
said the election was rigged you see how
they use weasel words to get through
that because
but the the tweet did not say that in
fact the tweet said it isn't rigged it's
fortified
so they use that as a manipulation
here's the best part so this one outlet
i'm not gonna name because they did me
the solid they they apologized corrected
immediately and
fixed the context in full which did
something amazing
in the full context from this pointer
article it says
tim poole's post was wrong it claimed
the election was rigged
i never said that i never said the
election was rigged i never said trump
really won
i've long said it's over biden won and i
got so many trump supporters who are mad
at me for for a long time
smack talking me saying he's not he's
you know he's he's going against trump
whatever
so they put this claim out there they
then got mad because what happened was
bird watch
twitter's independent user fact checking
system
determined that my tweet was incred in
fact correct
not misleading it said and all the
responses where people say tim poole is
just referencing a time magazine article
he's citing a
time magazine article so another outlet
sees the pointer article and
rewrites it because this is what news
outlets do
it's called journalism churn like they
just see a story they rewrote it
right in this the the context evolved
once more
pointer wrote in a post from
controversial youtuber
that stated the election was rigged they
didn't say i said it they said the post
stated it
so it's clever weasel words well this
next outlet said
tim poole who wrote the election was
rigged i reached out to
the writer and the the manager for the
company and i said
you know i humbly request a retraction
this is not correct i said
that it wasn't rigged that it was
fortified i was just referencing a time
magazine article
so in this new article this is really
amazing they included my tweet
and they removed the part where it said
who wrote tim poole who wrote the
election was rigged and said
in a tweet from tim poole who cited a
time magazine article
claiming that a cabal of wealthy elites
were fortifying the election by changing
rules and controlling the flow of
information
twitter flagged it as misleading and
with that simple correction a legitimate
correction
so my my thanks to the writer on that
that was very uh honorable
and this this guy's particularly lefty
uh
it changed the entire context of the
article before the article was saying
tim poole lied and twitter said it was
real news
by fixing the context of my tweet it
says tim poole was correct
the users correctly identified this and
pointer is angry about it
so the article has now become the
premier fact-checking organization for
facebook pointer
is outraged that i made a factual tweet
that was it was just a snarky statement
that users flagged it as not misleading
and made them mad because they lost
control of the narrative to a bunch of
random twitter users
so with that correction i'm actually
really really happy and uh
i'm not entirely hopeful that will
always be the case but that's good news
sounds like uh the dude from the second
article who's the company the second
i didn't name them um actually went and
read the time magazine article after you
requested the retraction and then was
like
whoa this is just um it just seems like
it i don't know if that's actually what
happened
the great the crazy thing about how the
media works whoa
whoa then you got this time article by
the way that
have you read that article yeah yeah i
did so psycho
there's a trick that i do on twitter
where i make statements that are vague
and i and i gotta admit i learned this
like from michael malus totally legit
like
i love his tweets when he would respond
to trump saying we don't deserve him
and you're like you don't know if it's
saying it's a good or bad i love it it's
brilliant
and so i started making tweets where i
would just try to avoid
a hard direct partisan opinion the
opinion would be a neutral positive or
negative opinion
and then you can see in the responses
from people what they think of you
so that tweet for instance where i said
time magazine said the election was
rigged i'm sorry they didn't say it was
rigged
was i insulting time magazine or was i
was i angry with time
for for lying or was i angry with the
cabal of wealthy elites truth be told
both to be honest
but i know to be precise with my
language
so what's interesting is this guy from
poynter the pointer institute they
decide who gets to be a fact checker for
facebook
he read my tweet and said oh that
controversial tim pool
claiming the election's rigged the other
guy just wrote what the guy said
but when he actually read the tweet he
took it at face value
tim poole is referencing time magazine
that's it
my question is if someone is to change
the rules of an election
is that not rigging the election well i
i i'm not
i didn't say that yeah i would not tim's
not making a statement he's just being
neutral
off the record he's just trying to you
know we're on the record right now the
the point is my issue is i'm not going
to come out and say
the election is rigged it's it's not and
it's fortified
time magazine said all right right time
magazine but then i said
they said it wasn't rigged because i was
just being snarky time magazine
literally said it wasn't rigging the
election it was fortifying it
the point i made in my video was how
would you define
rigging something if let's say you know
let's say ian and luke were going to
race
and then i tied luke's shoes shoelaces
together right see i was going to say
we'll just hobble one of you but you
went
i think i think hobbling is a reference
to tying a rope to a donkey's legs yeah
i think so
no i thought hobbling is where you get
like i watched a movie where this woman
just went
and just like smashed this guy's ankles
together yeah that sounds horrible
all right with a mallet look what film
was that oh my god
these are on the island let me put it
this way there's a reason why we're all
related to convicts
the rule changes uh benefited everybody
it was make it easier to vote but we
know
that democrats are more likely to vote
by mail so
while the rule change would have
benefited both sides democrats are more
likely to vote
so if luke and i were about to race and
i was like ah let's race on one of those
horizontal elevator things that at the
airports
where the ground is moving forward on it
and we run am i rigging the race
it would be more like if you yes because
i'm changing the physics of the race
if you said this uh let's say there's a
dude who's allergic to
peanuts and you were like we're gonna
race but
i think it's fair that we give everyone
a big jar of peanut butter for energy
well one guy you know peanut peanut
butter is normally good
your opponent can't eat it so you are
saying no no we're giving peanut butter
to everyone plus
it's not changing the rules they favor
us they did it covertly whatever they
did they did covertly which is
well if we knew no time no no that's
that's the fault of
like in georgia in pennsylvania where
these rule changes happened
it was publicly known but you rely on
the national media to come out and tell
you what was happening
so the issue was that th the question of
rigging is not about
it's it's not necessarily about whether
or not fraud occurred because that i
don't think i i don't think
that's an issue here the bigger issue is
were the changes constitutional
and uh and that's basically it the other
big news in that regard is that the
supreme court today said
now
the pennsylvania pennsylvania's been
swinging because we because i've covered
this so much
uh and we had sean put on the show
several times pennsylvania sued arguing
that the mail-in voting law was
unconstitutional because
their constitution in pa state says
absentee ballots must be for this reason
and then they created universal mail-in
voting which basically negated absentee
voting
the lower court said you are correct and
will likely win on the merits
and then it got i think it got appealed
to the state supreme court
the state supreme court said you're too
late the merits don't matter
this bill was passed in fall of 2019
therefore it's done
so they fought they filed an appeal to
the supreme court the supreme court
today said it's a moot point
trump's not going to be president so we
refuse to hear this clarence thomas got
angry
and he said he basically said if we
wouldn't hear the case
before the election and now we won't
hear the case after the election
we have not solved the problem of
breaking the rules in the election and
it is not a moot point and he was
he was pissed he dissented amazing he
was the only one
yeah i'm on the show
yes that would be incredible i would
love to have him he's amazing but
yeah he's this guy yeah he's a busy guy
um but
that'd be awesome he's a rad dude thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time